oh yeah love vegas
cool cause you know i don't know if you
heard the smith center you were at the
cabaret jazz you sang there is that
right
oh yeah yeah one of my favorite venues
the best sound system in america
unbelievable unfortunately because the
pandemic they've been no shows there and
they just announced that they're laying
off 160 people
oh yeah but we don't have to talk about
that we can talk about you being here
and
whatever you want to say about that
great cool
i don't know if we're ready to record
yet so we'll wait for the tech folks to
let us know that we're good to go
but thank you guys for doing this i know
it's part of a grind for you so we
appreciate it
our pleasure
how's the weather in vegas right now
actually it was a little bit cloudy this
morning but we're looking for an
afternoon high temperature in the mid
60s with overnight lows in the low 40s
[Laughter]
thank you for shopping at 8 news now in
las vegas
[Laughter]
do you guys get out to vegas besides uh
you been at cabaret tom have you been
out here
uh yeah i've been out there a couple
times you know for uh various um
uh i suppose gambling expeditions and
one time i
i i went out to nellis and flew where it
flew with the thunderbolts oh wow that's
an
f-16 yeah holy crap that's cool
yeah that was like one of the highlights
of my life as
a general aviation pilot to fly in an
f-16
wow do you mind if we mention that
sure okay uh thomas is a pilot
yeah but thomas otherwise your
expeditions to las vegas did not end up
in a hangover type
experience i hope no no not typically
i'm i i settle up to a craps table with
a ten dollar bill being like oh i hope
this lasts
long
[Laughter]
all right i've been told that we're
about ready to roll here so if you guys
are good to go we'll
get this little party started great
all right so i'll just count down and
start reading off the teleprompter and
act like i know what i'm talking about
here we go in three two one
great new cbs comedy from producer chuck
laura it's called be
positive now the series revolves around
a therapist named drew
and his adventures trying to protect a
wild woman named gina who just happens
to be his
future kidney donor all right so joining
me to talk about this series are the
stars thomas middleditch and anali
ashford hi thomas hi emily
hello hello hello hello thank you so
much for being with us thomas i want to
start with you the show we're told has
was inspired by the experiences of the
creator of the show
um marco pinette did he find out that he
really did need a new kindy and an
old acquaintance volunteered her own
that's
precisely the story yeah and there was
uh
some growing things along the way they
had to uh they had to teach each other
a thing or two but now uh they are
bound for life their dear friends they
marco make sure to call her every week
it's actually a really sweet story
when this is done i will not call analy
ever again but uh
[Laughter]
but it's nice that marco has that
relationship okay so we know uh both of
you from some of your previous work uh
thomas nominated uh for an emmy from
silicon valley anna lee you want a tony
and
you can't take it with you so what was
the draw to be part of a network
sitcom um
well this is sort of the best of the
best
of the bestest when it comes to network
sitcoms not only do we get to work with
the brilliant chuck lorre he's the
master of comedy
um but i also get to work with this guy
over here thomas middle ditch who's a
genius
and marco pinette is telling this
beautiful story from his life so
um all the stars have aligned and we're
really honored and grateful that we get
to share
a story with the masses right now that
reminds us all to stay connected to love
each other to
to open our hearts to kindness and to
win be positive
like for real also it's not just the
title of the show it's an attitude
amen yeah it's an attitude it's the
title it's a blood type it's all the
things
so for both of you uh obviously we have
this pandemic going on how do you do a
tv show during a pandemic
there's a lot of hand washing there are
a lot of
masks and there are a lot of nasal swabs
thankfully we somehow have the type that
only just
go in a little bit and don't like scoop
out your brain along with it
but yeah you know it's a lot of
protocols everybody's all the
departments have these different
pods and all these um you know
safety protocols come into place if you
know something happens
but uh yeah it's obviously a different
way of shooting we don't have a live
audience
but um you know we're making do we
the show must go on as it were and my
guess would be that just the fact that
there is a show
to do that's got to be you know kind of
exciting too
uh emily i know that you have uh
performed in las vegas and tom's i'm
going to get to you but emily tell me
about what you have done here in las
vegas
i am honored to say that i have
performed at the smith center
for a small residency twice it's one of
my favorite venues in the country
the best sound system in america uh and
las vegas is one of my favorite
audiences it was really a dream come
true getting to perform there
um i i ca i'm from denver originally and
we used to drive to vegas a lot
and as a kid that's where i would go to
dance conventions so circus circus has a
special place in my heart in a way that
very few places do well circus circus
has a special place in all of our hearts
in the
thomas do they still have hot the big
hot dogs
oh absolutely yes my mouth just that's
right next door it's lots of fun but we
can talk about that later
thomas i didn't know that you are a
pilot and that you had a special visit
here to las vegas
yes i was very very lucky and i was
invited out to nellis air force base and
flew in an f-16
with the thunderbirds we did all kinds
of
insane maneuvers i pulled nine g's and i
stayed awake the whole time
i barfed twice and i made it back safely
and at one point
i even i even flew it a little bit but
by that time i was so sick that i just
sort of flew in a straight line
but uh yeah it was a it was a dream come
true
a dream come true a dream came true
through
there you go all right hey before we go
with the subject of your show
being about a kidney donor i wanted to
ask you both personally have you thought
about organ donation after being part of
the show
yeah you know my mom is actually the
recipient of two cornea transplants so
i'm
very close to the land of organ donation
and always check the donor box
uh when i when i get my driver's license
and when my son was born
we donated the cord blood it's a really
easy thing to do my friends
just just tell them when you get there
when i have this baby i want to donate
this cord blood it saves lives it's
awesome
i've got it on the driver's license as
well awesome all right so the show is
thursday nights right here on eight news
now be positive and
we're totally positive about the show
and thank you guys so much for
taking time to talk with us today and
we'll see you on the tube
take care thanks for having us
all right you guys thanks that was
awesome thank you we'll let you move on
to the next one
but you don't get to talk about vegas on
the next one okay